if we do this we'd be going in
short-handed yeah you mean cuz he killed
all that friend we owe this to everyone
who's not in this room to try
[Music]
it's not about how much we lost it's
about how much we have left
[Music]
wizzy vengers
we gotta finish this
you trust me I do
[Music]
you could not live with your own failure
where did that bring you
[Music]
back to me
tickets and everybody it's worn Avengers
end game tickets went on sale today this
morning and with it we got some amazing
new footage in a special look from
Marvel Studios this morning it's a 1
minute special look for Avengers in game
with all new footage and I thought we'd
get before the movie comes out so let's
dive right into it and break it down if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe I'm doing a new Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain the special look
opens with a shot of the Avengers
compound and it starts with banner
saying if we do this we'll be going in
short-handed he's talking about here is
what we've actually predicted for some
time now and that is that the Avengers
will actually go and try to fight Thanos
not too long after the snap in the very
beginning of Avengers endgame they're
short-handed because half of the
Avengers got killed in the snap and at
this point in time they probably don't
have Tony Stark either or if he is back
he doesn't go with them because he's too
hurt to go with them I've Natasha with
her red hair it looks like she could be
somewhere in Japan or maybe she's at the
Avengers facility still but we get the
same line from her that we got from the
other trailers everybody who's not in
this room to try obviously talking about
going to fight Thanos to try and undo
the snap rocket and nebula sitting
together and you can tell by the looks
on both of their faces and the fact that
they're holding hands that nebula just
told rocket that all of the guardians of
the galaxy fell victim to Thanos a snap
and are now gone the only two left of
their guardians family and then the very
next scene is Toni reuniting with Pepper
Potts nebula and Toni make it back to
earth and they make it back to earth
pretty early on in the movie then get
our true first look at Iron Man's new
mark 85 iron man armor and he's flying
over New York but it looks exactly like
the concept art photos that we've seen
the promo art photos that we've seen and
the new toy figures that have just been
released as well it looks like the
classic Iron Man armor from the comics
and it looks really awesome we also know
from some other leaks that this new
armor has some new weapons as well and
then we see Hawkeye who is finally back
at the Avengers compound all tatted up
its back and meets up with the other
Avengers pretty early on in the film as
well remember Kevin Feige said that most
of the footage that we see in the
trailer
or TV spots is most likely going to be
from the first 15 to 20 minutes of the
movie it doesn't mean all of the footage
but he said most of it probably will be
so it seems like the original Avengers
reassemble and unite in the first 15 to
20 minutes of the movie we have the same
scene that we saw from the last trailer
with Captain Marvel and Thor and this
time you can see Stormbreaker pretty
clearly I know some people thought that
his hammer might have been Mele near
from the trailer that we saw before but
it's definitely Stormbreaker then we
have this one scene with all of the
Avengers and they're getting up and
they're looking at something and in this
scene we have Hawkeye war machine Iron
Man Captain America nebula rocket
ant-man
and Black Widow the only heroes that are
not in the scene are the Hulk Thor and
Captain Marvel though this could be the
scene where Captain and Marvel and Thor
are talking or this could have something
to do with professor Hulk ever it is
it's important because all of the heroes
get up and give it their attention it
most likely does have something to do
with Captain Marvel and Thor because
it's in the same room as that scene we
have this scene that we've all been
waiting for
Iron Man and Captain America reuniting
they're clearly in the middle of
something and Tony Stark a Steve Rogers
do you trust me and they shake hands and
he says I do
so finally Iron Man and Captain America
working together again now if you look
in the background you can see that most
of it is destruction we can see cars
flipped over and ambulance and police
slides in the background that could be
back in time to the original Battle of
New York at this point scene leaked
photos of this however Captain America
is still wearing his new scale uniform
and then the leaked set photos he's
wearing the uniform that he wore in the
first Avengers film so there's a few
things that could be happening here one
is that using CGI they make Captain
America appear like he's still present
Captain America and not in the past two
they could just be using barf technology
to revisit the events three it's simply
present time but I'm leaning towards
this is probably time travel and they're
just covering it up with CGI making
Captain America appear as if he is still
in his scale uniform so we don't know
that his time travel because Tony does
appear to be wearing the same outfit
that he wore in those league set photos
have a scene with the Bennet are flying
away from a planet and I'm not quite
sure that's earth it's not very blue and
there are two other planets extremely
close by perhaps Tony and nebula somehow
land on another planet they get the
parts they need to fix
and then they head home or perhaps this
is just them leaving Titan for the first
time because it does look very red like
Titan is and then the next scene is what
appears to be most of the Avengers going
to fight Thanos in the Benatar said
they're not going to get Tony and nebula
they couldn't use the Benatar unless
Tony and nebula were already back at
that point so Tony and nebula are
already back and now they're going to
fight Thanos we know from the Disney
shareholders footage that was shown that
Captain Marvel says they need to go
fight Thanos right away have Captain
Marvel now and believe that they can
beat him with her power and you can see
everyone in this scene with the
exception of Bruce Banner and Tony Stark
very closely and slow it down you can
actually see nebulas head behind Thor on
the right side over his left shoulder
then an upcoming scene you can see
nebula and war machine clearly on the
ship together we have a really
heartbreaking scene with Tony Stark
looking at a picture of him and Peter
Parker know that tony is going to feel
an extreme amount of guilt and sadness
due to the fact that Peter Parker was
victim of the snap and died in his arms
we know that Peter was like a son to
Tony so Tony will probably have a really
hard time dealing with this in the
beginning of the movie when he's looking
at the photo we hear the voice of Thanos
saying you could not live with your own
failure so you know that Tony is
struggling with it but then he says and
where did that bring you back to me then
we see fan OSIS ship the sanctuary - and
we get a look at nebula and war machine
and nebula looks like she's experiencing
just a ton of emotions in this scene
right here probably a lot of hate and a
lot of fear at the same time as she
approaches thanasis ship but we then
have a very interesting scene with Thor
and Rocket Thor looks in disbelief and
so does rocket and we know from the
previous trailers that it seems like
Thor and rocket go off alone on a
separate mission perhaps they go back to
Ned of Lear but wherever they go and
whatever they find they seem to be in
clear disbelief of what they are seeing
there seems to be a little bit of the
orange glow in Thor's eyes so maybe he's
seen Heimdall somehow maybe Heimdall or
Odin is communicating with him somehow
from Valhalla then we have a scene with
Captain America on his floor he has his
shield back most likely the same scene
from the other trailers and then we
finally for the first time get a look at
the nose we see him appear from a blue
beam of light which is most
likely from the sanctuary - it's not the
space stone because we've seen him use
that before and it doesn't look like
that but it seems like they've tracked
Thanos down and they're fighting on a
distant planet to avoid hurting earth
any further and as he appears we see
Tony Stark and his new mark 85 armor
walking towards him eyeing him down
ready for his rematch against Thanos and
then we have the coolest scene of this
trailer the original three Avengers Iron
Man Captain America and Thor walking
towards Thanos and as you can seethe
anos is just sitting down waiting for
them we can see his double bladed sword
but I can't see the Infinity Gauntlet
now of course they could have just
edited it out of the trailer but Thanos
almost looks defeated in this scene we
see when he arrives with the blue beam
of light and he's standing up in that
scene but in this scene he's sitting
down perhaps he's just waiting for the
Avengers but he actually looks sad in
this scene and a little defeated perhaps
the Infinity Gauntlet was damaged and he
could not use it against the Avengers
and they actually beat him but that's it
for this new special look at Avengers
endgame with all new footage this really
was more footage than I thought we'd
ever get for this movie with each
trailer and special look they give us
way more than I expected to see again
tickets went on sale for Avengers
endgame this morning so be sure to get
them before they're all sold out be sure
to let me know what you thought of this
trailer and let me know if you picked up
on anything specifically let me know
what your favorite part was be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
and marvel and so you can enter the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]